>> WE HAVE THE SECRETARY
RESPONSIBLE FOR SECURING OUR
BORDER, AND OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM, WHO DOESN’T RECOGNIZE
THESE CHARTS AS BIG A PROBLEM.
I FIND THAT EXTRAORDINARY AND
EXTREMELY DAMMING AND I’M ALL
FOR LEGAL IMMIGRATION BUT WHAT
WE HAVE DONE INSTEAD IS JUST
OPENED THE DOORS.
>> WE SPEAK OF LAWFUL PATHWAYS
IN SUPPORT OF THEM, AND YET THE
PRIOR ADMINISTRATION TORE
THOSE DOWN TOO.
>> BEFORE WE DISCONTINUE THE
BLAME GAME HERE HOW MANY
CHILDREN WERE PROCESSED OVER A
THREE-YEAR PERIOD THROUGH THAT
PROGRAM?
>> BE PLEASED TO PROVIDE THAT
DATA.
>> I THINK IT’S ABOUT 5,000
CHILDREN.
STEVE: RIGHT, EXACTLY.
LAWMAKERS, AS YOU CAN SEE THE
SENATE GRILLING DHS
SECRETARY MAYORKAS OFFER THE
ONGOING SURGE AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER AND NOW STATE
LEADERS ARE JOINING THE CAUSE AS
20 REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS HAVE
SENT A LETTER TO THE WHITE HOUSE
URGING THEM TO TAKE ACTION ON
THE BORDER IMMEDIATELY.
ONE OF THE GOVERNORS IS ON THE
BORDER, SIGN THAT LETTER,
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT JOINS
US TODAY FROM AUSTIN.
GOVERNOR, GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING, STEVE, HOW YOU
DOING?
STEVE: I’M DOING OKAY.
YOU KNOW, MITT ROMNEY HAD THAT
GRAPHIC YESTERDAY THAT SHOWED
HOW OUT OF CONTROL THE NUMBER OF
APPREHENSIONS AND PEOPLE
CROSSING INTO THE COUNTRY, BUT
ACCORDING TO SECRETARY MAYORKAS,
GOVERNOR, THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
THAT IS NOT HOW IT LOOKS.
>> SO I DON’T KNOW IF SECRETARY
MAYORKAS AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION EITHER DON’T HAVE
A CLUE WHAT’S GOING ON OR  THEY
ARE PURPOSEFULLY MISLEADING
THEIR FELLOW AMERICANS, BECAUSE
HERE ARE THE NUMBERS ON THE
NATIONAL LEVEL WITH REGARD
TO THE BORDER PATROL, THEY
APPREHENDED THIS LAST MONTH AND
THE MONTH OF APRIL, MORE THAN
170,000 PEOPLE.
THAT IS A 10-FOLD INCREASE OVER
THE PRIOR APRIL, WHERE THEY
APPREHENDED ABOUT 17,000 PEOPLE,
BUT ALSO, I CAN TELL YOU WHAT’S
GOING ON ON THE GROUND WITH
REGARD TO THE STATE OF TEXAS,
BECAUSE I HAVE DEPLOYED THE
TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AS WELL AS THE NATIONAL
GUARD, AND THEY HAVE APPREHENDED
ABOUT 30,000 PEOPLE WHO CAME
ACROSS THE BORDER AND
THEY’VE ARRESTED MORE THAN 900
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
BUT STEVE, THERE’S SOMETHING
ELSE, A NEW DYNAMIC ABOUT WHAT’S
GOING ON ON THE BORDER THAT
AMERICANS INTO ED TO KNOW ABOUT
AND THAT IS THE INCREASED
APPREHENSION OF FENTANYL COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER.
YES THERE MAYBE PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER BUT THERE’S
DANGEROUS DRUGS COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER FOR YOUR AUDIENCE WHO
MAY NOT KNOW, 2 MILLIGRAMS OF
FENTANYL IS A FATAL DOSE, AND SO
KNOW THIS.
WE HAD OVER AN 800% INCREASE,
APRIL OVER APRIL ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF FENTANYL THAT HAS
BEEN APPREHENDED BY THE TEXAS
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
WE HAVE OBTAINED ENOUGH FENTANYL
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER TO KILL
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THE STATE
OF NEW YORK, AND SO THIS IS A
VERY DEADLY SITUATION, HAPPENING
ON THE BORDER.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BETTER
WAKE UP.
HOWEVER, STEVE, THIS IS THE DEAL
, BECAUSE OF WHAT TEXAS
IS DOING ON THE BORDER IF TEXAS,
THAT IS SECURING THE BORDER, WE
WANT BIDEN TO PAY FOR IT.
STEVE: IT SEEMS FAIR, ABSOLUTELY
FAIR, BECAUSE YOU’RE DOING THE
JOB THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE DOING BUT
THEY REFUSE TO.
GOVERNOR, ALSO, YOU’VE BEEN BUSY
I KNOW YOU’VE JUST SIGNED THE
ALCOHOL-TO-GO BILL, AND THAT
IS GOING TO REALLY HELP STRUGGL
ING RESTAURANTS, BECAUSE
NOW, IN ADDITION TO YOUR TAKE-
OUT FOOD YOU’LL BE ABLE TO
GET A COCKTAIL OR  A BEER OR
WINE OR  SOMETHING LIKE THAT AS
WELL.
>> WELL FIRST, FOR THE SETTING
OF WHERE WE ARE IN TEXAS RIGHT
NOW, ALL OF OUR RESTAURANTS ARE
100% FULLY OPEN AND THEY HAVE
BEEN FOR A WHILE.
THIS ALCOHOL-TO-GO WAS ONE OF
THE MEASURES THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE DURING THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC WHEN RESTAURANTS
WERE NOT ALLOWED TO BE OPEN 100%
, AND SO MANY RESTAURANTS
OWNERS HAVE SAID THAT THIS
ALCOHOL-TO-GO PROGRAM THAT
WE ALLOW THEM TO UNDERTAKE
DURING THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC, THAT IS WHAT KEPT
THEM OPEN AND OPERATIONAL AND
HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR THAT THEY
MAY HAVE HAD TO SHUTDOWN, BUT
THE POINT IS, THAT BOTH
RESTAURANTS AS WELL AS TEXANS,
LIKED ALCOHOL TO GO SO MUCH, WE
DECIDED TO MAKE IT PERMANENT LAW
STEVE: WELL THERE YOU GO AND NOW
IT IS.
ALL RIGHT, GOVERNOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US FROM
AUSTIN.
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.